just for everybody are you are you a
flat earther yourself or no
no why would the earth be flat that's
that's a ruse to discredit people who
know that the middle and it's required
to the audience know this you don't
believe the earth is flat
no not at all okay i mean when bill
casey was first on the oprah winfrey
show he was my original source at nasa
and he said they faked the moon landing
in order to discredit them they said oh
then you must believe that the earth is
flat also you know i mean come on it the
shape of the earth doesn't have anything
to do with the corruption let me
continue let me continue so so a few
things i'm going to take both sides of
the argument because this is how i get
to the truth so i'm going to give
arguments from both sides and then you
uh uh you know give your uh rebuttal to
it and we'll go from there when when he
said there's one in ten thousand chance
in 1969 technology they can land on the
moon one in ten thousand is not a big
number just so you know like in my mind
i don't go like you know because
winning the lottery say one in 6.8
billion whatever the number is that's
like ridiculous one in ten thousand you
know
back in 19 what is that paper done in
1903 the new york times said the chances
of man flying a plane will take a
hundred years of what you've you've read
the quote before which is like
mathematically impossible then nine
months later the wright brothers flew
plane so that one i would set that part
aside ten percent of americans today
believe that men never landed on the
moon so this is not like that you're
quoting uh unfortunately that's a survey
they always quote when they do an
article about the people who who think
the moon landings are fake that that's
from 22 years ago because the correct
survey today which they don't want to
show is one out of four people we
already have three out of four people
i'm sorry what do you have that for you
to say the correct one is one out of
four what's the source
oh
there's been multiple sources on that
the the problem is they're quoting an
old one in order to diminish the growing
number of people who know that the
mainland you know what i'm saying is
what's the what's the updated one who
who is the what's the credit i don't
know you have to you have to i have it
linked uh in the references of my book i
don't have that at hand at the moment
the the point is
that this is the first time that
technology has gone backwards in the
history of the world now it's impossible
it's impossible for technology to go
backwards how can we have 1 000
times greater we have 1 000 times
greater capability yeah again
this is to the moon
50 years ago it doesn't make any sense
i'm looking at 10 percent
pc mag is 10 percent uh yeah but they're
they're quoting from 2019 they're
quoting a gallup poll from 1999. they
quote the same one all the time 1999 the
gallup poll was six percent so 1999 if
you can pull up this thing so we can
show it as well while we're doing the
editing in 1999 it was six percent today
it's 10 but still what i'm trying to say
is 10 is a big number that's not a small
number 10 percent is still a big number
to say 10 believe this never happened so
if you like this sort of short clip from
an interview i did click over here to
watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]